ich würde die foto kollegen bitten
langsam die klaxons vielen dank meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen herzlich
willkommen in der bundespressekonferenz
an alle hier im saal und diejenigen die
uns an dem bildschirm verfolgen
ich darf heute hier
bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn dem
präsident des robert koch instituts
professor doktor lota bieler und den
geschäftsführer der fördergesellschaft
für sozialforschung und statistische
analysen manfred güllner hier willkommen
heißen herbst bekommen auch einsehen
wir bekommen heute eine einschätzung zur
krone lage in urlaubszeiten und das
thema kuroda
unter den gesichtspunkten der eu
ratspräsidentschaft bvb thematisch
einsteigen erlauben sie mir kurz ein
paar vorbemerkungen die
bundespressekonferenz eine
regierungsunabhängige organisation wir
organisieren hier an dieser stelle
pressekonferenzen und ermöglichen dass
unsere mitglieder und die mitglieder des
vereins der ausländischen presse hier
ihre fragen stellen können in besonderen
zeiten werden wir übertragen unter
anderem auf dem sender phoenix und
begleitet von gewerben dolmetschen
bisschen heute daniel meier und werner
der ziele
auch wenn sie herzlich willkommen und
ein dankeschön ist dass sie diese dem
dolmetscher ermöglichen und damit würde
ich kein können wir beginnen verspannten
das wort
rolf lieber herr professor wieder herr
professor gunnar meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren ich möchte mit ihnen
heute über die aktuelle lage zu beginn
der sommerzeit der urlaubszeit sprechen
die es erst mal grundsätzlich stand
heute erfreulich ich möchte aber auch
mit ihnen darüber sprechen was uns was
mich besorgt auch mit blick auf diese
urlaubszeit und zudem einen ausblick
geben auf die eu-ratspräsidentschaft wir
haben in dieser woche das erste eu
gesundheitsminister treffen der
informellen rat die natürlich auch sehr
sehr stark diese präsidentschaft von
corona & co wird 19 geprägt sein wird
der professor villa wird dann noch
weitere zahlen zum infektionsgeschehen
in deutschland auf der welt liefern und
der professor gönner präsentiert in
kurzen zügen eine von uns beauftragte
studie auch zu sozioökonomischen folgen
und einschätzungen in der bevölkerung zu
corona wir haben unser land bis hierhin
gemeinsam gut durch diese krise geführt
die bürgerinnen und bürger haben einen
großen anteil daran und ich kann allen
bürgerinnen und bürger nur ein großes
dankeschön dafür sagen dass sie auch
unter stress aufeinander geachtet haben
und einander geachtet haben die
infektionszahlen befinden sich auch
stand heute morgen weiterhin auf
niedrigem niveau
wir haben knapp 5000 akute infektionen
in deutschland
es gibt immer mal wieder überall in
deutschland lokale und regionale
aussprüche und die zeigen im übrigen wie
schnell das virus sich verbreiten kann
wenn man es ihm zu leicht macht in
bestimmten situationen ob es die große
familienfeier ist ob es bestimmte
situationen sind bei einem gottesdienst
oder eben bestimmte arbeits und
wohnbedingungen in dem moment kann das
virus sich sehr schnell ausbreiten das
beruhigende bis hierhin stand heute ist
das ist den gesundheitsämtern vor ort
dafür auch ein großes dankeschön an alle
die dort mit großem einsatz tätig sind
immer gelungen ist infektionskette zu
unterbrechen die verläufe zu
identifizieren und damit diese ausbrüche
tatsächlich auch lokal begrenzt zu
halten
das ist erfreulich trotzdem bin ich
überzeugt davon wir sollten uns nicht in
falscher sicherheit wiegen
auch wenn es sich manchmal so anfühlt
und auch wenn viele verständlicherweise
ungeduldig sind diese pandemie ist noch
nicht vorbei wir sind noch mitten in der
pandemie das gilt vor allem mit blick
auf die welt die infektionszahlen
weltweit sind so hoch auch im täglichen
steigerungen so hoch wie noch nie zuvor
das gilt besonders für die usa und
südamerika
aber das gilt auch und ich denke das ist
für uns alle auch ein stück mahnung das
gilt auch für regionen die ja ist vor
kurzem auch gut dastanden wie etwa
israel japan oder südkorea wo wir sehen
dass auch dort die zahlen wieder steigen
deswegen müssen wir sehen die gefahr
einer zweiten welle ist real
wir sollten daher wachsam bleiben wir
sollten nicht übermütig werden und
gleichzeitig bin ich zuversichtlich dass
genau das uns gemeinsam gelingt und
gelingen kann
es geht auch darum das erreichte zu
sichern
ich finde das sind wir auch all denen
schuldig die ja zum teil große kosten
und mühen auch in den letzten monaten
hatten um eben das gemeinsam zu
erreichen das sind die vielen
unternehmer die vor finanziell
schwierigen teilweise existenziellen
fragen stehen das sind die eltern mit
ihren kindern die über wochen monate
geschlossene kitas und schulen erleben
mussten was eine besondere stressige
situation war das sind viele bürgerinnen
und bürger die auf vieles verzichten
mussten und noch immer müssen in den
letzten monaten und ich find all
denjenigen sind wir es schuldig dass wir
das erreichte das unter großen mühen und
kosten erreichte sichern
daher habe ich eine bitte an alle
bürgerinnen und bürger bitte halten sie
abstand bitte halten sie sich an die
empfohlenen hygienemaßnahmen und bitte
tragen sie überall dort wo es in
geschlossenen räumen empfohlen ist die
alltags masken mit diesen relativ
einfachen mitteln können wir alle dazu
beitragen rückschläge zu vermeiden und
das infektionsgeschehen weiterhin
niedrig zu halten und im zweifel sollten
wir einmal mehr
ein mal zu vorsichtig sein als einmal zu
wenig das gilt auch und gerade im urlaub
wenn natürlich sind urlaubszeiten
reisezeiten zeiten gestiegen und
steigender mobilität und mobilität macht
es diesen virus immer leichter sich zu
verbreiten im urlaub treffen wir auf
mehr menschen als sonst im alltag im
zweifel auch mehr menschen die wir nicht
kennen noch fremde
wir können im zweifel beim reisen
kontakte nicht vermeiden
auch kontakte wo der abstand nicht
eingehalten werden kann und bei der
rückkehr in die heimat tragen infizierte
möglicherweise das virus dann weiter und
deswegen will ich auch ausdrücklich
sagen dass die bilder die wir am
wochenende von der deutschen liebste
insel gesehen haben von mallorca mich
besorgen müssen sehr aufpassen dass der
ballermann nicht ein zweites spiel wird
als synonym dafür dass dort wo ohne
einhalten von regeln und dorf ohne
aufeinander achten gefeiert wird und ich
sage noch einmal ich verstehe die
ungeduld dabei aber dort wo eben
miteinander gefeiert wird das
infektionsrisiko besonders hoch ist und
wenn dann die rückreise ansteht und
einsetzt damit das risiko im übrigen
auch für alle anderen im flieger aber
eben auch für alle anderen zu hause
entsteht
deswegen geht es darum gemeinsam gerade
in diesen reise und urlaubszeiten genau
das zu verhindern das heißt im übrigen
nicht dass wir automatisch mit einer
zweiten welle im herbst und winter
rechnen müssen wenn ich habe gerade die
maßnahmen dazu gesagt das können wir als
gesellschaft gemeinsam verhindern wir
haben es eben auch schon einmal
geschafft
eine solche welle zu brechen und die
pandemie im zaum zu halten und das kann
uns wieder und weiterhin gelegen dabei
setzt sich vor allem auf vernunft und
nicht zuallererst auf verbote die
meisten wissen dass gruppenreisen zum
ballermann dass großveranstaltungen das
umarmen zur begrüßung oder das einkaufen
ohne maske momentan keine guten ideen
sind und außerdem sind wir auch auf den
einen möglichen anstieg der
infektionszahlen
besser vorbereitet als noch zu beginn
der pandemie
wir haben besser gelernt mit dem virus
zu leben und wir wissen auch mehr über
dieses virus das früh waren und
reaktionssystem steht es gibt
ausreichend tests um im falle von
aussprüchen infektionen schnell durch zu
durchbrechen
die nationale strategie zeigte wirkung
allein letzte woche wurden knapp 500.000
menschen getestet das ist die höchste
zahl seit beginn der korona pandemie in
deutschland getestet das sind noch
175000 mehr tests als noch vor vier
wochen
das zeigt dem dass unser ansatz stärker
auch präventiv und den reihen testung zu
testen ein unterschied macht gerade dann
auch in ausbruchs situationen wie in
gütersloh wir sind besser in der lage
unsere intensiv kapazitäten zu steuern
auch regional besser zu steuern wenn
sich entsprechende bedarfe entwickeln
auch kurzfristiger zu steuern
das gesundheitssystem hat insgesamt
besser gelernt auch die versorgungswege
zu trennen so dass eben im
gesundheitswesen mögliche
infektionsrisiken minimiert sind
außerdem haben wir die korona waren app
die hat noch nicht ganz deutschland
installiert aber doch mittlerweile über
15,5 millionen bürgerinnen und bürger in
deutschland das sind deutlich mehr als
manch einer prognostiziert hat und das
sind mehr als in allen anderen
europäischen ländern zusammen noch das
ist eben ein zeichen dafür dass die
allermeisten bürgerinnen und bürger das
als team spiel betrachten diesen kampf
gegen das virus und wissen dass wir da
gemeinsam ein unterschied machen können
im übrigen mit diese woche die app auch
auf türkisch gelaunched zur
eu-ratspräsidentschaft dieser woche
treffe ich mich mit meinen
amtskolleginnen und kollegen zur
informellen tagung in berlin
genaugenommen treffe ich mich vor allem
mit den beiden weiteren kolleginnen und
kollegen aus portugal und slowenien im
rahmen der trio ratspräsidentschaft die
hier in berlin anwesend sein werden und
die anderen kollegen schalten wir in
einer video-konferenz dazu geprägt ist
diese ratspräsidentschaft zumal bei uns
im gesundheitsressort natürlich durch
die kurve 19 pandemie in dieser krise
haben wir erneut erfahren
für europäer zusammenstehen müssen um
gefahren abzuwehren und dass wir
souveräner werden müssen souveräner als
europäische union um uns zu schützen das
ist unser ziel da geht es aus meiner
sicht vor allem und drei punkte zum
einen strukturen zu entwickeln
die europa unabhängiger machen von der
produktion von arzneimitteln und
medizinprodukten von anderen regionen es
sollte sich nicht in china entscheiden
ob wir ausreichend schutzmasken oder
medikamente für unsere ärztinnen und
ärzte und pflegekräfte in berlin
amsterdam oder madrid haben wir wollen
das europäische robert-koch-institut des
cdc stärken ausbauen als europäische
behörde die nach europa hinein aber im
übrigen auch wie das amerikanische
center for disease control das
amerikanische robert-koch-institut sich
auch stärker außerhalb von europa dann
engagieren kann ich war letzten
september im kongo hat dort die ebola
situation hier vor ort angeschaut und
dann sieht man wie stark auf das
amerikanische cdc dort im rahmen der
vero arbeit engagiert ist und ich finde
da kann auch europa mehr leisten darauf
wollen wir einen fokus legen und das
dritte damit verbundene ist dass wir die
rolle europas im rahmen der
präsidentschaft stärken wollen innerhalb
der vero der weltgesundheitsorganisation
ist ein herber rückschlag für die vero
dass die usa ihren austritt angekündigt
haben um so wichtiger finde ich ein
verstärktes engagement europas und vor
allem ein koordiniertes verstärktes
engagement europas in der wehr auch um
notwendige reformprozess voranzutreiben
deutschland ist dieses jahr mit
zusätzlichen mitteln die auch der
bundestag mit dem nachtragshaushalt zur
verfügung gestellt hat der größte
geldgeber staatliche geldgeber zur
weltgesundheitsorganisation mit über 500
millionen euro insgesamt
die wir zur verfügung stellen und damit
auch ein klares bekenntnis ablegen zur
arbeit der weltgesundheitsorganisation
in diesem sinne ist die pandemie auch
eine chance für europa die sollten wir
ergreifen um den auftritt der
europäischen union in der welt und für
die welt zu stärken
vielen dank herr sparen damit machen wir
nahtlos weiter und das wort morgen man
die damen und herren sehr geehrter herr
minister sicherte professor will
zunächst ein paar worte zur lage welt
war als minister spahn hatte es bereits
um schrieben wir haben mit dem stand
heute mehr als zwölfeinhalb millionen
fälle die uns bekannt sind und darunter
wurden für über 561.000 todesfälle auch
vermittelt es ist tatsächlich so dass in
einem kurzen zeitraum von fünf tagen nur
die zahl von elf auf zwölf millionen
gestiegen ist das heißt diese pandemie
ist also weltweit wirklich sehr sehr
stark unterwegs und nahezu alle länder
dieser welt melden fälle von kogit
neunzehnten wir sehen vor allen dingen
einen anstieg von neun fällen aus
ländern die trotz steigender fallzahlen
die maßnahmen wie zb kontakt
beschränkungen lockern beziehungsweise
gelockert haben
das gilt zum beispiel für indien oder
pakistan
auch südafrika israel die usa oder auch
einige länder in osteuropa
da kann man das betrachten diese locken
sind teilweise auch wieder
zurückgenommen worden etwa in israel
oder auch in vielen bundesstaaten der
vereinigten staaten
wie sieht die lage in deutschland aus
und wir haben heute stand 0 uhr
dreizehnter siebter insgesamt 198 1963
fälle offiziell von den
gesundheitsämtern gemeldet bekommen und
darunter sind neun 1064 todesfälle
gemeldet worden
die zahl der genesen ist sehr hoch
185000 100 wenn esther spahn sagte es
gerade damit sind etwa rund 5000 fälle
uns bekannt die wir als aktive
infizierte fälle einschätzen
tatsächlich ist es so dass sich die
anzahl der neuen fälle auf einem
vergleichsweise niedrigen niveau
stabilisiert hat über die letzten wochen
und das ist definitiv eine sehr gute
nachricht denn das ist die folge dessen
dass eben wie viele mitbürger mitbürger
diese erste welle
mit runter gebracht haben und mit ihrem
verhalten dafür gesorgt haben dass die
ausbreitung des virus sehr effizient
eingeschränkt werden kommt aber es kommt
eben immer wieder zu einigen wenigen
mann/frau größeren häufig zu mehreren
kleinen lokalen ausbruchsgeschehen in
einigen kreisen und die müssen wir
sorgfältig im auge behalten
auch in großstädtischen ballungsgebieten
gibt es immer noch eine relevante zahl
von neuinfektionen
es gibt weniger ausbrüche in
krankenhäusern und in alten und
pflegeheimen
auch ist es so dass die zahl der täglich
übermittelten todesfälle in den letzten
wochen deutlich gesunken ist und diese
zahl hat sich wirklich auf einem sehr
niedrigen niveau stabilisiert
entscheiden ist dass die anzahl der
neuen fälle sich in einer größenordnung
bewegt mit der die gesundheitsämter
umgehen können das ist ja wichtig dass
die gesundheitsämter ihre kontakt
nachverfolgung durchführen können um
ausbrüche rasch eindämmen zu können
und auch das ist richtig die
behandlungskapazitäten in deutschland
sind insgesamt weiterhin so gut dass wir
auch für intensivbetten und
beatmungsgeräte genügend zur verfügung
stehen haben ein kurzes wort zu den
tests auf das hatte minister sparen
bereits angesprochen
in der letzten in der kalenderwoche 27
also anfang juli wurden fast eine halbe
million tests durchgeführt in
deutschland und tatsächlich ist die
kapazität der tests in deutschland die
liegt inzwischen bei über 1,1 millionen
pro woche das ist eine sehr sehr gute
basis denn damit können wir fälle sehr
schnell finden um diese dann auch
entsprechend zum beispiel zu behandeln
bzw auch in quarantäne zu stecken damit
die verbreitung des virus eingeschränkt
wird aber insgesamt ist die pandemie
eben nicht vorbei im gegenteil auf der
welt haben wir ja so starke zunahmen wie
noch gar nicht vorher sie ist also weder
in deutschland noch weltweit
wir sollten alle weiterhin und ich denke
wir müssen weiter wachsam sein
ich kann auch wirklich jeden bieten sie
alle bitten dass wir weiterhin uns an
die regeln halten
denn das virus
kann sonst wieder fuß fassen
unachtsamkeit nutzte dieses virus aus es
ist ein binärer organismus der nichts
weiter möchte als sich zu vermehren und
venwegen die chance geben dann dann tut
er das
wie schnell das gehen kann das haben wir
in den letzten wochen wirklich in
anderen ländern gesehen wir schauen
immer ein zeitfenster das temporär
begrenzt ist und wir müssen die dynamik
immer im auge halten
ein baustein der bekämpfung in
deutschland ist die corinna war mehr als
15 5 millionen menschen haben die schon
heruntergeladen
diese app hilft dabei infektionsketten
früher zu brechen aber auch nicht mehr
und nicht weniger
sie schützt nicht vor ansteckung regeln
bleiben weiterhin gültig und sie bleiben
weiterhin wichtig abstand hygiene
alltags masken dieser dreiklang ist sehr
sehr wichtig und sollte weiter beachtet
werden die entwickler der korona app
arbeiten kontinuierlich daran
fehlermeldungen zu optimieren bzw die
fehlermeldung natürlich auszuräumen
die bei der app nutzen auftreten zu
analysieren die probleme zu beheben und
die app wird kontinuierlich
weiterentwickelt und ja nicht nur haben
viele menschen die app heruntergeladen
sondern die funktioniert auch wir haben
mit stand heute 500 tele tanz sind
ausgegeben worden das heißt das also
rund 500 menschen die positiv auf das
saas kauf 2 virus getestet wurden die
gelegenheit hatten die möglichkeit
hatten das auch über die map an andere
zu melden
das heißt sie konnten die anderen nutzer
der app warnen
wie viele menschen allerdings konkret
dann gewarnt haben das können wir nicht
sagen das liegt am dezentralen ansatz
der korona wahrnimmt alle daten der
nutzerinnen nutzer werden verschlüsselt
und ausschließlich auf dem eigenen
smartphone gespeichert die
risikoüberprüfung findet auf dem
smartphone statt eine risiko
benachrichtigung also die statusanzeige
erhöhtes risiko wird nur
der oder dem nutzer selbst zum schluss
möchte ich ihnen noch erste ergebnisse
einer antikörper studie mitteilen dass
sind zwischenergebnisse einer von vier
antikörper studien die das
robert-koch-institut federführend leitet
die studie hat im april begonnen
diese studie heißt see blue coat das
heißt es geht um studien von
blutspendern
bislang wurden rund 12.000 blutspender
untersucht und wir sehen dass bei diesen
proben bislang 1,3 prozent dieser proben
positiv waren also etwa eine von hundert
proben in der konnten wir antikörper
gegen das sauerstoff zweijähriges
nachweisen
das unterstreicht unsere annahme dass
vermutlich der großteil der bevölkerung
noch keinen kontakt mit dem virus hatte
und weiterhin empfänglich für eine
infektion ist aber ich möchte betonen
diese studie ist nicht repräsentativ für
die gesamte bevölkerung denn blutspender
dürfen nur solche erwachsenen seien die
gesund sind also menschen mit
grundkrankheiten sind zum beispiel nicht
erfasst
es könnte auch sein dass die
infektionsrate bei ihnen deutlich anders
aussieht
bislang wurde der blutspende studie bei
männern doppelt so häufig antikörper
nachgewiesen über frauen und was
überraschend war die blutspender
blutspenderinnen zwischen 40 und 49
jahren waren am wenigsten betroffen
hatten also am wenigsten antikörper das
ist allerdings anders
bei den an das rkw von den
gesundheitsämtern übermittelten melde
fällen da gehört diese altersgruppe zu
jenen wo wir am meisten infektionen
sehen
bei personen unter 80 jahren die meisten
antikörper also die höchsten raten
hatten wir bei personen zwischen 25 29
jahren also bei blutspenderinnen und
blutspendern
hier wurden etwa bei 1,9 prozent der
proben antikörper nachgewiesen also da
ist es so dass rund zwei von 100
blutspenden antikörper aufheben
das sind zwischenergebnis muss weiter
untersucht und evaluiert werden die
studie läuft weiter
ich möchte zum schluss all denen danken
die zu dem studio zu dieser studie
beitragen wir werden insgesamt rund
60.000 proben noch untersuchen bis
september ich danke den 13
blutspendediensten dem konsiliarlabor
für carola wir uns an der charité als
auch dem institut für medizinische
virologie am uniklinikum fragen vor die
uns hier unterstützen
danke ihnen herzlich und noch eine
bemerkung zwischendrin mit blick auf die
zeit und wir haben eine folge pk und ich
habe schon eine sehr lange frageliste
würde ich sie bitten sich nach
möglichkeit etwas kurz zu fassen damit
noch alle fragen platz haben vielen dank
vielen dank
das bundesgesundheitsministerium hat ja
eine rekonstruktion beauftragt eine
relativ breite studie noch durchzuführen
wie die vorliegenden einzelnen daten
auch wirklich sinnvoll ergänzt das ist
eine kombination aus befragung und
medizinischen testen
das konsortium besteht aus der charité
mit den provisionen posten und winter
als er die medizinische koordinierung
vornimmt und die logistik der testung
und ergänzt wird das auf der
medizinischen seite von den professoren
notlagen und nürnberg der universität
köln den ökonomischen teils heißt die
befragung stylen hat das ifo institut
und forsa übernommen
wir haben jetzt die ersten
befragungswelle abgeschlossen die
medizinischen testen die zu hause
vorgenommen werden wobei ein
rachenabstrich und eine blutentnahme
erfolgte sind angelaufen im herbst wird
eine zweite welle erfolgen das ist wie
sagt auf repräsentativer basis wir haben
jetzt 30 tausend repräsentativ
ausgewählte personen bundesweit gefragt
so dass wir hier sehr detaillierte
ergebnisse sowohl regional als auch was
einzelne wurden kann man dank vorlegen
können ich kann heute jetzt in
anbetracht der mahnung derzeit nur ein
paar kernergebnisse ganz schnell in
vorstellen das eine was wir sehen können
dass krone auch im juni wo wir die
dunja durchgeführt haben trotz der
eingetretenen lockerung sich mit kroner
beschäftigen sind fast drei viertel
ich sage ich beschäftige mich fast
täglich mit corona ich lasse ich
informiere mich denkt darüber nach
hier ist interessant dass bei den
jüngeren ist internet persönlich als 50
prozent die decken auch noch andere
dinge bei den älteren über 70 und vor
allen dingen über die 80 hier hin da ist
es so dass fast 90 prozent sich mit
bewohner beschäftigen die schon von
minister sparen angesprochene zweite
welle bedrückt auch die meisten menschen
ist halt nur wenige nämlich 20 prozent
ist für unwahrscheinlich dass es eine
zweite welle gibt die mehrheit rechnet
entweder mit hoher wahrscheinlichkeit
damit das sind 40 prozent oder knapp 40
prozent sagen wir schätzen die
wahrscheinlichkeit 55 die 1
also hier ist durchaus eine große sorge
vorhanden hier gibt es interessante
regionale unterschiede
für am wahrscheinlichsten halten die
bremer dass das eine zweite
infektionswelle gibt und auch unbesorgt
nisten in anführungszeichen sind die
bürger in sachsen anhalt wir haben dann
ja die sozioökonomischen folgen und
schon angeguckt die wir im juni
feststellen konnte ich ihnen
kurznachrichten wenn das eine ist dass
trotz der schwierigen ökonomischen
situation im augenblick nur eine
minderheit wirklich sehr besorgt ist
dass die crawler krise sie selbst in
finanzielle schwierigkeiten bringt das
ist ein zehntel also zehn prozent sagen
dass wobei natürlich diejenigen deren
einkommen schon gesunken ist die größten
ängste haben die in kurzarbeit sind und
die vor allen dingen die selbstständigen
und die arbeiter die die größten ängste
haben wir haben uns dann angeguckt wie
es die einkommensentwicklung seit
februar
hier können wir sehen dass 20 prozent
sagen unser einkommen ist im vergleich
stand juni im vergleich zum vorjahr
gesunken
20 prozent allerdings fünf prozent sagen
dass
nichts mit grüner zu tun und tiroler
bedingt sind es 15 prozent der einkommen
gesunken ist das sind natürlich
logischerweise die in kurzarbeit
befindlichen sind sind die mittleren
altersgruppen und vor allen dingen die
selbst stehenden zwar alle gruppen wir
haben auch landwirte auf monster großen
fahrzeuge haben hier befragen können und
die frei berufen und die sonstigen
selbst stehen nicht die gruppe mir noch
einmal genau anschauen dann können wir
sehen dass nur knapp 40 prozent ihre
tätigkeit in der kroner krise
unverändert haben fortführen können
das haben 31 22 prozent ihre arbeit ganz
eingestellt und 39 prozent die arbeit
eingeschränkt das betrifft hier
überproportional frauen vor allem die
alleinerziehenden frauen unter den
selbstständigen die zu fast 85 prozent
betroffen sind fast 40 prozent musste
ihre tätigkeit einstellen
gegründet waren überwiegend die
gesetzlichen vorgaben aber auch andere
betriebliche gründe
ein teil hat auch sorge für infektionen
dazu geführt die tätigkeit einzustellen
die umsätze sind bei fast 70 prozent der
selbstständigen eingebrochen seit der
kuba-krise seite februar
das betrifft auch unter den
selbstständigen er die die einen
geringern der umsatz schon gehabt hatten
und wiederum die alleinerziehende frauen
unter den selbst stehen 85 prozent
umsatzrückgänge zu verzeichnen hatten
die selbst stehen haben dann alle
möglichen maßnahmen getroffen um sich
über wasser zu eins haben die privaten
ersparnisse genutzt eine staatliche
soforthilfe haben ein paar bekommen geld
bei freunden gepumpt bei den abhängig
beschäftigten ist ganz generell die
folgen doch nicht so dramatisch es sind
knapp 80 prozent die sagen ich konnte
ununterbrochen arbeiten zeitweise
freigestellt
17 prozent permanent ausgeschieden sind
im augenblick nur vier prozent der
abhängig beschäftigten das gehalt hat
sich auch bei 80 prozent der abhängig
beschäftigten im gegensatz zu den
selbstständigen julia titel großen
einbrüche haben nicht verändert bei 15
prozent hat sich das einkommen
verringert hier wiederum die unteren
sozialen schichten die geringverdiener
die hauptschulabsolventen die arbeiter
die am meisten davon betroffen sind auch
bei der kurzarbeit sind es vor allen
dingen gearbeitet
24 prozent sagen ich bin die kurzarbeit
von allen sind es 13 prozent
hochrechnung kommt dass ungefähr auf die
bekannten zahlen zwischen 65 wir sehen
aber auch das ist durchaus auch bei
einigen nicht bei der mehrheit aber doch
bei knapp 40 prozent positive dinge gibt
die man in folge der krise erlebt hat
ich sagte dass man schlagwort es geht in
richtung entschleunigung und hat mehr
zeit man hat auch mehr zeit um sich mit
der familie zu beschäftigen auch hier
gibt es unterschiede im westen sind es
knapp 40 prozent
die sagen es gab auch positive dinge
durch kroner die sich verändert haben im
osten sind es im osten des landes nur 28
prozent eine deutliche differenz die am
häufigsten positive erfahrung gemacht
haben sind die beamten und wir haben ein
bildungsgefälle von den hauptschülern
sind es nur 27 prozent von denen mit
abitur oder studium sind es 40 prozent
dann ist das sparen hat ja schon darauf
hingewiesen dass die bevölkerung
eigentlich insgesamt sich diszipliniert
verhalten hat das liegt auch daran dass
die meisten sagen ich hatte eigentlich
keine schwierigkeiten nur wenig
schwierigkeiten
die regelung und empfehlungen bei den
einschränkungen zu befolgen wenig
schwierigkeiten hatten 30 prozent und
sehr schwierig war es nur für 17 prozent
also auf 4 sieht man dass die
bevölkerung nicht nur daran denkt
sondern auch die eigentlich
beschlossenen maßnahmen umgesetzt
das führt auch dazu dass sich das
abschließend noch referieren darf dass
die während der krise getroffenen
maßnahmen durch die politik auch im
nachhinein etwa die einschränkung im
märz eingeführt worden sind für richtig
halten das sind 65 prozent 17 prozent
sagen hätten noch strenger sein müssen
sind also über 80 prozent
die die maßnahmen für richtig halten
oder noch hätten lieber strenger gesehen
dass sie zu streng waren sahen insgesamt
nur 17 prozent allerdings mehr
ostdeutsche als westdeutsche
und wenn man nach ländern sich dass man
auch schlägt abschluss und in sachsen
sind das die meisten visagen waren zu
streng die auflagen im märz in cottbus
fahren die wenigsten gesagt es um 13
prozent das ist nicht dass es streng
gewesen ist
männer empfangen die auflagen mehr als
zu streng als frauen
das land wird genau und sie einmal ganz
kurz unterbrechen entschuldigen sie mit
blick auf die zeit und die frage ist es
schon sehr sehr lang vielleicht können
wir die restlichen details wirklich
gezielt auf die fragen hin band fahrer
vielleicht nur eine wenn auch zu ende
die ihr die letzte zahl dass auch die
lockerung der einschränkungen von über
80 prozent für richtig gehalten werden
also die maßnahmen der politik werden
also von der großen mehrheit für richtig
befunden
vielen dank für ihre ausführungen
deswegen auch immer an die liebe
kolleginnen kollegen
vielleicht könnten sie sich erst eine
frage beschränken und wenn wir die zeit
haben dann setze ich gerne noch mal auf
die liste und die erste frage hat teil
jungen
ich habe zum einen eine frage zum urlaub
machen und eine zum blutspenden die geht
ganz kurz sparen sie sprachen von dem
mann soll es den virus nicht zu leicht
machen dann frage ich mich warum der srg
und das gesundheitsministerium die
empfehlungen der bh und der euro würde
für sicherheit im flugverkehr ignoriert
wo gesagt wird dass im flugzeug abstand
zu halten ist der bär hat strengere
empfehlungen als die asa
und da geht es darum dass die ja so
empfiehlt nur jeden zweiten sitzplatz zu
besetzen und möglichst auch nur jede
zweite reihe
warum machen sie es den virus hierzu
leicht und zum blutspenden würde ich von
den sparren gerne wissen wie sie das
empfinden als schwuler mann dass sie
nicht blut spenden dürfen
warum enden sie das nicht jaja jungen
vielen dank ich fange mit letzterem an
die frage beschäftigt mich auch aber
nicht als schwuler mann sondern als
bundesminister für gesundheit als der
ich verantwortung trage für diese fragen
der bund deutsche bundestag hat gerade
das gesetz so geändert dass auch die
bundesärztekammer und die institutionen
die die regeln festlegen wer blut
spenden darf und wer nicht dazu
gezwungen sind das regelmäßig zu
überprüfen
der prozess findet gerade statt den
werden wir entsprechend begleiten weil
ich den punkt den fehler machen
insbesondere schule männer dass sie
grundsätzlich nicht
blutspender sein können gut
nachvollziehen kann und ich deswegen
gemeinsam mit den zuständigen
institutionen schauen möchte wie wird
eine auflösung schaffen die gleichzeitig
das infektionsrisiko weiter minimiert
und gleichzeitig möglichst vielen das
blut spenden möglich macht also thema
sehe ich und wir sind in gesprächen zur
frage des fliegens ist dort wichtig dass
wir ein gemeinsames europäisches
vorgehen haben das bringt jetzt nichts
insbesondere auch bei den flügen über
deutschland hinaus gehen ins eu ausland
wir national und abgestimmte maßnahmen
ergreifen deswegen haben wir uns
innerhalb der europäischen union
abgestimmt stimmen uns auch weiterhin ab
welche vorgaben es für den flugverkehr
gibt und welche empfehlungen wichtig
finde ich im übrigen gerade beim
flugverkehr zu sehen in welcher
geschwindigkeit die luftströmung die
auch von oben nach unten geht was auch
wichtig ist für die frage wie sich die
aero sohle verbreiten dass die luft sehr
stark ausgetauscht wird viel frischluft
zugeführt wird und zudem auch
entsprechende hepa filter wie sie
genannt werden also die mit der höchsten
erfüllter kraft auch was dieses virus
angeht eingesetzt werden
das thema muss man natürlich trotzdem
immer wieder beachten insbesondere die
frage wie auch die verpflichtung zu
masken tragen wie es ergibt
nach dem was mir jedenfalls anekdotisch
berichtet wird ich bin selbst seit dem
nicht linie geflogen aber wie es mir
anekdotisch berichtet wird nicht immer
voll umfänglich und durchgesetzt wird
und die erwartungen sollten wir schon
mindestens haben übrigens auch an die
fluggesellschaften das wenn die dinge
schon so sind dann das masken tragen
auch mit der entsprechenden konsequenz
durchgesetzt ich wollte von einem gel
erkennen müssen haben sie das als
ekd-chef vertreten können das im
flugzeug kein abstand gehalten werden
muss obwohl die whu und die nasa das
empfiehlt was ist denn mit dem lka haben
sie da andere erkenntnisse und ersparen
die europäische abstimmung ist also dass
man die empfehlungen ignoriert also die
es gibt ja eine gruppierung die im
rahmen und für die whu diese auf diese
empfehlungen gibt und die geben keine
anderen empfehlungen als das
robert-koch-institut es gibt eine andere
arbeitsgruppe die sehr deutlich sagt
dass es entscheidend ist dass die
filterung im flugzeug wir unterscheiden
natürlich teilweise ältere baujahre in
flugzeugen von neu und das ist sehr
wichtig für die neuerungen das sind ich
weiß nicht wie viel prozent das sind
also für die regelhafte linienflugzeuge
ist den luftaustausch und die filterung
sehr sehr wichtig sehr effizient gibt
das masken tragen wurde ebenfalls
angesprochen ist ein wichtiger punkt
ich denke ein
großes oder eine größere problematik ist
der zugang zu flughäfen und das auf
reihen der passagiere wenn es zum
einchecken geht hier
es ist sehr sehr wichtig dass hier die
regeln eingehalten werden die
abstandsregel denn dort besteht
natürlich auch ein mögliches risiko bin
ausführung von dem professor wähler
nichts hinzuzufügen
dann bin ich mit der nächsten frage ja
ich würde gerne auch noch mal dort einen
haken herr spahn
sie haben davon gesprochen weil er man
darf kein zweites spiel werden das sagt
herr söder auch aber mich würde auch da
interessieren ganz konkret die bürger
hier sind sehr diszipliniert und so
weiter herr will hat gerade über die
zugänge zum flughafen gesprochen
warum kann man sich auf europäischer
ebene dann nicht zu schärferen regeln
irgendwie kommen dass man sozusagen da
auch versucht gerade bei dem thema
flugzeuge und flughäfen stärker zu
versuchen das virus nicht wieder ein zu
schleppen wir haben lange darüber
gesprochen ob die kontrollen an
deutschen flughäfen bei china flügen
ausreichend waren oder nicht ob es da
auch versäumnisse gab und es scheint
dass man hier wieder in das gleiche
problem hineinläuft nun zum ersten ganz
grundsätzlich ist eher die frage gewesen
die man diskutieren kann ob man früher
als europäische union die
einreisebeschränkungen aus drittstaaten
hätte ergreifen sollen das ist aber ein
anderes thema als das dass sie gerade
ansprechen darauf lege ich schon wert
und im zweifel jahren nachhinein hätte
man früher auch beginnen sollen als
europäische union drittreisen ein
drittstaaten einreise zu beschränken
gleichwohl will ich darauf hinweisen
dass das erste und einzige land das in
china flug vollständig eingestellt hat
italien gewesen ist und offensichtlich
allein das einstellen des flugverkehrs
nicht vor der verbreitung des virus
geschützt hätte und hat eher was die
frage angeht der verhaltensweise und der
abstimmung insgesamt haben wir sehr klar
gemacht auch in den gesprächen der gibt
ja auch viele länder die gerade
außerhalb der europäischen union auf uns
zukommen wo es darum geht die vom
tourismus sehr stark auch wirtschaftlich
abhängen was wieder gehen kann und was
nicht und ich habe
die erwartung dass an länder und auch
die gegenseitige erwartungen innerhalb
der europäischen union dass wenn wir ja
alle unter großen kosten und mühen das
infektionsgeschehen insgesamt in europa
so runter gebracht haben und einige
ländern mit noch viel hören auch
gesellschaftlichen und wirtschaftlichen
kosten als wir in deutschland das wir
dann auch ein gemeinsames verständnis
darüber haben im grundsatz was geht und
was nicht geht
und im übrigen war das was wir gesehen
haben an bildern auch nicht erlaubt
es war noch kein spanier soweit ich das
überblicken konnte hauptsächlich
jedenfalls die das dort gemacht haben
und die frage stellt man sich dann schon
auch an die eigenen landsleute was genau
also ich sage nochmal ich verstehe
irgendwie dass man den drang hat manche
haben jetzt erst recht modus ne das
erlebte ich ja alles im jeder hat ja in
eigenen bekannten und familienkreis im
grunde beides die die sehr sehr
vorsichtigen und diejenigen die schon
erste fragen stellen auf dieses virus
ist überhaupt zugegeben hat und
dazwischen gibt es alle schattierungen
und so wie es das in jedem
bekanntenkreis im zweifel gibt gibt es
das in der gesellschaft und gibt's das
auch bei den urlaubern und trotzdem
finde ich müssen wir sehr sehr klar
machen an die wenigen wahrscheinlich die
sich nicht an regeln halten wollen dass
sie damit den erfolg und das erreichte
für alle anderen gefährden und dann
müssen regeln auch durchgesetzt werden
dieses gemeinsame verständnis haben wir
in der europäischen union ich werde es
aber auch noch mal und ich die
kolleginnen und kollegen auch in allen
entsprechenden stellen ansprechen wir
dürfen das erreichte nicht gefährdet ich
würde an dieser stelle eine frage online
dazu nehmen und halte es hier außer dass
wir erst mal eine frage pro kollege oder
kollegen nehmen vl vom
gesundheitspolitischen
informationsdienst fragt an sie herr
sparen und an professor wieder werden im
zusammenhang mit der korona krise noch
eine anonymisierte bewegungsdaten der
bevölkerung erfasst und
das gefährt geweitet bundesweit oder in
zusammenhang mit hotspots die
anonymisierten bewegungsdaten werden ja
nicht vom uns über regierungsseitig
erfasst sondern das sind die
telekommunikationsunternehmen die diese
daten haben die kann man glaube ich auch
durch einfaches darf ich das großkonzern
nicht nennen einfache suchen online auch
auffinden und die gesteigerte mobilität
wie man ja tatsächlich sehen kann ist ja
sehr spannend dass auch nachzuvollziehen
seid also erst mal wie es runter gehen
und wie es eben jetzt auch wieder steigt
ist auch nachvollziehbar oder das sind
keine regierung gesammelten daten wie
die frage unterstellt sondern sind daten
der kohle telekommunikationsunternehmen
anonymisiert und gar nicht zuvörderst
auf regierungsseiten verfügbar aber
arbeitet auch mit diesen daten soll ich
war ja wir kommen tatsächlich daten zur
verfügung gestellt die sind aggregiert
und anonymisiert
das heißt also wir können dort lediglich
bewegungsprofile auf bestimmte regionen
nachzeichnen aber die sind aggregiert
und anonymisiert daten die uns zur
verfügung gestellt werden wobei die
klage gar nicht um das vielleicht noch
zu ergänzen
daraufhin attackierte ob die von der
regierung erfasst und ausgewertet wurden
sondern generell
ich bin mit der nächsten frage bayern
[Musik]
neuer zdf ersparen eine frage zum thema
zweite welle welche lehren ziehen sie
aus ländern wo es eine solche zweite
welle gerade aktuell gibt etwa aus
israel
welche lehren ziehen sie daraus für die
politik in deutschland wenn sie auch an
die gefahrenherde denken jetzt wo man
eine solche zweite welle erwarten kann
und eine ganz kurze zweite frage bereits
angesprochen wurde ja die korona app und
auch die fehlermeldungen von denen viele
user berichten wann erwarten sie dass es
da ein update gibt dass diese
fehlermeldung behebt und wer ist dafür
verantwortlich
zuerst einmal sehen wir vor allem dass
der schlüssel ist und bleibt tatsächlich
in dem was wir gerade unter a ha regel
abstand halten hygiene-empfehlungen
beachten und dort wo
empfohlen und angezeigt den
geschlossenen raum alltags masken tragen
dass das tatsächlich den größten
unterschied macht und die frage wie sehr
wir das im alltag miteinander
beibehalten und ich weiß genau wie alle
anderen auch dass das maske tragen
manchmal nicht immer schön ist und
manchmal auch ein bisschen nervig aber
im vergleich zu allen anderen denkbaren
konsequenzen einer verbreitung des virus
doch ein vergleichsweise mildes mittel
ist damit auch umzugehen das zweite ist
dass wir weiter sehr umfänglich testen
auch das ist finde ich eine lehre aus
den entwicklungen in vielen ländern ist
das testen weiterhin breit bleibt und
nicht was übrigens durchaus dem pandemie
planung vorgesehen ist in anderen
situationen dass man irgendwann testen
konzentriert auf bestimmte bereiche
bestimmte risikosituation wir in diesen
bei diesem virus sehr breitem testen
geblieben sind und auch bereit bleiben
mit system mit rein präventiv und dort
wo ausbruchsgeschehen ist aber ist eben
tatsächlich auch machen und das dritte
nach allem was mir berichtet wird es das
auch ein thema in den ländern wo es
wieder zu steigerungen gekommen es ist
das konsequente kontakt nachverfolgen
dass wir das auch das ist ja für die
gesundheitsämter natürlich auch über
wochen und monate durchaus ziemlich
mühsam und herausfordernd die die
ressourcen zusammen zu halten auch
innerhalb der kommunalen verwaltung die
wurden ja vielfach zusammengezogen die
gesundheitsämter gestärkt und jetzt wo
die anderen aufgaben auch wieder stärker
anfangen der schule andere weiterhin die
gesundheitsämter stark zu halten
kontaktpersonen nachverfolgung
konsequent betreiben zu können darin
nicht weiterhin der schlüssel und auch
das ist für mich eine lehre aus dem was
wir an verschiedenen stellen sehen das
vierte und letzte und da bin ich bei der
bahn app ist die frage dass wir vor
allem bei gestiegenen mobilität kontakte
nachverfolgen können müssen die anonymen
sind deswegen kam aus meiner sicht auch
diese
kroner waren nicht wirklich zur
richtigen zeit in einer zeit wo wir im
pfleger übrigens würde mich im zweifel
jenseits des fliegers andere
verkehrsmittel die nicht so eine lüftung
und solche filter haben mindestens
genauso besorgen wo wir in verschiedenen
situationen nebenleuten sitzen in der
nähe von leuten reisen in der u-bahn
dass dort die korona waren et kontakte
informieren kann die wir über normale
nachfragen gar nicht erreichen würde
weil sie wissen noch mit wem sie
vorgestern abend essen sein wir müssen
aber im zweifel nicht mehr wer in der
s-bahn weiter saß oder ein
und deswegen ist diese app in gerade
auch dafür sehr wichtig sie wird
regelmäßig upgedatet und und also bei
mir jedenfalls ich habe schon mehrfach
die dt das update herunter geladen und
da werden bugs und fehler auch behoben
und erkenntnisse die gewonnen werden was
noch besser ergeht wie das mit jeder app
so ist sie lernt durch das umfangreiche
nutzen sozusagen lernen die entwickler
dazu
und das machten werden das robert koch
institut die zusammen mit denjenigen die
sie entwickelt haben
die frageliste wird länger die zeit
kürzer muss kürzer werden das war jetzt
natürlich an den kollegen mit der
nachfrage gerichtet und ich nehme jetzt
am thema app noch eine frage online dazu
die orders von ap fragte man sich
ersparen
ob sie schon anfragen anderer länder
erhalten haben die bei der erstellung
einer app und dem entsprechenden back
end um hilfe und rat bitten und ob
deutschland denn bereit wäre
großbritannien behilflich zu sein
jetzt zuerst einmal ist die app in
weiten teilen oder vollumfänglich open
source weswegen wir auch sehr leicht
nachzuvollziehen und nach zu machen wenn
man so will sozusagen und gleichzeitig
klar gibt es anfragen aus verschiedenen
ländern zum teil seines
informationsanfragen zum teil auch eine
grundsätzliche abfrage im bereitschafts
kooperation da ist die ist natürlich da
und überall wo es gewünscht ist
unterstützen wir auch sehr sehr gerne da
aber in national zu allen ländern
wie in deutschland die debatte zur app
eine sehr politische und öffentliche ist
ist im zweifel der wunsch schon vor
anfragen öffentlich zu machen glaube ich
bei den kollegen aus den anderen ländern
nicht über ausgeprägt also wir sind im
engen kontakt da wo gewünscht ist mit
anderen ländern gleichzeitig das würde
ich auch noch mal sagen jetzt die
deutschen waren in allen europäischen
ländern im app store verfügbar
wie gesagt bei den drei sprachen wir
arbeiten auch an weiteren sprachen und
wo gewünschte sind wir jederzeit zur
kooperation bereit
aber es ist eben auch für jedes land
irgendwie auch eine frage habe ich so
den eindruck für uns war es dass er
vielleicht auch ein bisschen nationaler
prestige zu einer solchen app zu kommen
ich finde es umso wichtiger dass wir
aber bei der kommission auch das wird
vorangetrieben das back end schaffen
dass die unterschiedlichen apps dann
austauschen können
im falle etwa zum beispiel einer
positiven und die konkrete frage zu
großbritannien abgedeckt auch um mit den
britischen kollegen sind wir im engen
austausch und gleichzeitig freue ich
mich dass die information dass es auf
der welt mindestens eine funktionierende
krone app gibt auch die kollegen in
großbritannien mitarbeiter so sehen noch
mal eine frage zuerst angesprochen warum
gibt es nicht nur eine diese deutsche
app warum wurde ich von anfang an
versucht eine europäische abzuschaffen
oder beziehungsweise warum versuchst es
sich im nachhinein diese systeme
zusammenzuschalten ist auch der franzose
der ihr durch die u bahn fährt
vielleicht die deutschen nutzer warnen
kann mit seiner französischen rap und
was das alles mit älteren smartphones
sind ja oft nicht tauglich für diese app
wird daran noch gearbeitet oder
interessiert das jetzt nicht weiter
sehr geehrter herr will zum ersten liegt
das daran dass es halt auch sehr
unterschiedliche konzepte gibt sie
wissen dass wir uns für ein dezentrales
freiwilliges konzept entschieden haben
wo und der professor will hat noch mal
darauf hingewiesen auch keinerlei daten
ich verstehe die frage die wir auch
öfter kriegen die viele sind jetzt
positiv gesehen
fehler wurden informiert und anderes
mehr gibt es bestimmte regionen wo es
vermehrt auf tops unter fragen die wir
kriegen auch von kolleginnen und
kollegen hier von ihnen die wir auch
nicht beantworten können mit einem
dezentralen freiwilligen konzept andere
länder haben sich für andere konzepte
entschieden auch was zentrales
datensammeln angeht und anderes mehr und
dann ist es natürlich mit
unterschiedlichen ansätzen nicht per se
gleich kompatibel gewesen
gleichwohl ist es technisch wird daran
gearbeitet eben ein backend ein server
zu entwickeln
idealerweise betrieben und die macht das
ja auch von der europäischen kommission
auf europäischer ebene die es dann
möglich macht entsprechende
positivmeldungen auszutauschen das ist
in der entwicklung braucht aber
natürlich auch seine seine zeit und
ansonsten gilt das was ich vorhin gesagt
habe ist die deutsche app auch das heißt
die deutsche unsere bewohner waren es
beim robert-koch-institut auch verfügbar
in allen anderen europäischen app stores
und mittlerweile auch in den usa wenn
ich richtig den usa noch nicht auch
nicht an den arbeiten wir noch die
älteren smartphones ist die situation
ist so dass gut 80 85 prozent derjenigen
die ein mobilgerät haben ein handy haben
ein smartphone haben das entsprechend
nutzen können aber es tatsächlich so ist
dass es eben für die älteren technisch
auch nicht geht zum einen weil das aber
nicht unsere entscheidung ist die
entscheidung der hersteller eben und da
können wir es lange über die
abhängigkeit von bestimmten
amerikanischen grosskonzern diskutieren
hilft mir aber jetzt in der konkreten
situation nicht eben die
geschäftspolitik haben diese älteren
geräte nicht mehr entsprechend die
software abzudecken und diese
bluetooth-technologie die low energy mit
geringem batterie verbrauch im
hintergrund gearbeitet diese bluetooth
low energy technologie gibt es auf den
älteren geräten so nicht und deswegen
kann es dann auch nicht mit geringen
könnte es gar nicht dann so arbeiten
ersparen zu der eu ratspräsidentschaft
zwei fragen ob sie haben erwähnt dass
ein ziel sein muss
medikamentenproduktion nach europa und
deutschland zurück zu verlagern keine
abhängigkeit von china zu haben wenn sie
sagen ob das für alle medikamente
zutrifft oder ob sie so eine
prioritätenliste haben dass der eine
aspekt und der zweite aspekt können wir
uns auch da auf eine frage beschränkt
man sich setzen wieder mehr geben auch
mit der in graz präsidentschaft zusammen
bei der bh wo sie haben gesagt dass die
eu stärker werden sollen ist das ein
ziel das jetzt schon der deutschen
ratspräsidentschaft verwirklicht werden
soll oder sollte man da die
amerikanischen präsidentschaftswahlen
erstmal abwarten
zum einen hering was die frage der
medikamente angeht
nein es geht ausschließlich nicht darum
jetzt sozusagen das gesamte viele
tausende ja auch wirkstoffe umfassende
medikamenten polo zigtausend portfolio
zigtausende im zweifel wieder
vollständig in europa zu produzieren es
geht darum für bestimmte und die muss
man dann miteinander definieren im
prozess gibt es auch bestimmte
wirkstoffe auch produktion in europa zu
haben um im fall der fälle sich darauf
verlassen zu können wir haben zum
beispiel gerade auch ich habe gerade per
verordnung verpflichtet die
krankenhäuser bestimmte
intensivmedizinische medikamente nicht
für zwei wochen sondern seit drei wochen
zu bevorraten um uns vorzubereiten auf
alles was kommen könnte weil ich glaube
jetzt ist gerade die bessere zeit den
vorrat zu erhöhen
als dann eben wenn es möglicherweise
auch insgesamt wieder kritischer werden
könnte und wir müssen gemeinsam mit den
eu kollegen einfach in der liste
entwickeln
der besonders sensiblen wirkstoffe um
die es geht für die wir auch wieder
produktion anreizen wollen da müssen wir
drüber reden wie geht's um
investitionszuschüsse geht es um preise
also genau diese frage welche
instrumente die möchte ich gerne konkret
machen
das wird sich ja nicht alles während der
eu-ratspräsidentschaft in diesen sechs
monaten lösen aber erst mal konkret zu
machen diese debatte die seit eineinhalb
jahren geht ist ein teil unserer debatte
am donnerstag im rat im informellen dem
wir haben bei der wm
will ich ausdrücklich sagen ist jetzt
ein einjähriger prozess mit dem
austrittsschreiben der der läuft mit
bezüglich der usa dass ich dass wir ein
hohes interesse daran haben oder haben
soll und dass die vereinigten staaten
mitglied der weltgesundheitsorganisation
bleiben sie sind ein gründer ein
entscheidender mitgründer sie sind ein
entscheidender vor antreiber in der
sache in den projekten aber auch
finanziell der whv der
weltgesundheitsorganisation übrigens
auch viele projekte in europa werden
durch die usa finanziert insbesondere in
osteuropa
wenn es auch um die frage von polio
ausrottung geht
ich glaube so weit tuberkulose programme
im osteuropäischen raum aber eben auch
einfach ein engagierter mitspieler
partner
das habe ich ja in den letzten zwei
jahren schon erleben dürfen in der in
der eu und die usa drängen ja vor allem
auch von diesen reformprozess seitens
der eu koordiniert zu begleiten
auch auch ein stück führung dabei mit zu
übernehmen natürlich unter einbindung
anderer weltregionen aber eher mit einer
europäischen stimme darum geht es aus
meiner sicht dazu gehört die frage wie
die hilfsprogramme und der hilfs arm der
mersey bereich gestärkt wird und auch
unabhängiger wird von dem politischen
bereich
die frage wie technische
wissenschaftliche hilfskraft rennen von
den politischen fragen ist er eines was
von anfang an auch in dieser krise eine
rolle gespielt hat zum beispiel und wie
wir auch die frage der finanzierung so
regeln dass nicht-staatliche geldgeber
eine weniger starke rolle spielen müssen
so muss man es ja formulieren die nicht
staatlichen geldgeber haben wir deswegen
so eine starke rolle weil die
staatlichen für viele der programme
nicht ausreichend mittel zur verfügung
stellen wir haben noch 30 minuten und
ich habe noch elf fragen daraus ergibt
sich die länge die für jede frage bleibt
hiervon hat die nächste frage geht an
beide
wenn das virus sozusagen eine art
unsichtbare reisender ist das ist ja der
kern ihrer beschreibung und die einzige
möglichkeit diesen unsichtbaren
reisenden sozusagen die maske vom
gesicht zu nehmen als testen testen
testen das war der slogan von beginn der
kampagne an
testen testen testen und jetzt hören wir
von ihnen dass sie nur die hälfte der
zur verfügung stehenden
testmöglichkeiten ausnutzen warum wäre
es nicht die beste möglichkeit eine
relative sicherheit in der bevölkerung
zu schaffen wir betroffen ist oder nicht
wenn sie sagen alles was wir an test
kapazitäten haben nutzen wir einstellen
es zur verfügung waren nur die hälfte
grundsätzlich steht die gesamte test
kapazität die ja in den laboren
abgerufen werden kann
zur verfügung aber wir haben immer sie
haben einen zusatz vergessen den
jedenfalls wir seitens des
bundesministeriums für gesundheit immer
gemacht haben testen testen testen aber
gezielt weil der pcr test der test
umsatz q2 nachzuweisen eben eine
momentaufnahme ist während des trainings
gesehen der betrieb wurde ja drei vier
wochen vor diesem ausbruch vollständig
durch getestet gab es eine gute block
zwei handvoll infektionen und schon drei
vier wochen später 1500 infizierte
das zeigt das einmal durch testen nicht
reich sondern das entscheidende sind
konzepte die dann in bestimmten
bereichen regelmäßiges testen reihen
testen vorsehen so wie das jetzt bei den
schlachthöfen in vielen bundesländern
gemacht wird ein oder zwei mal jede
woche durch testen so wie wir es
empfehlen und vorsehen bei jeder
aufnahme von neuen patienten in die
krankenhäuser sowie es angeordnet werden
kann in bestimmten situationen
regelmäßig jede woche pflegepersonal und
medizinisches personal zu testen so dass
es am ende darum geht ich bin bei ihnen
viel zu testen und diese kapazitäten
werden nicht irgendwie per anordnung
oder oder oder so nicht genutzt sondern
sie werden moment nicht abgerufen auch
von denjenigen menschen sehen wir haben
heute morgen gut 200 neuinfektionen
gehabt wir haben halt insgesamt auch
natürlich ein test geschehen auf
die uns geschehen auf niedrigem niveau
in dem moment wo zahlen sich irgendwo
verändern werde natürlich auch viel mehr
tests wieder gemacht gütersloh wurden 40
45.000 tests gemacht innerhalb weniger
tage für solche situationen müssen wir
auch kapazitäten vorhalten damit man sie
dann schnell abrufen kann
aber es macht am ende testen daneben vor
allem sinn aus groß bezogen und als
reinen testo aber nicht einfach weil das
in falscher sicherheit wiegt jeden
einfach mal irgendwie testen wohl kein
kontakt da war keine symptomatik kein
sonstiger irgendwie grund sollte also am
ende wirklich nur eine sekunden
momentaufnahme ist sie können das labor
denen die praxis verlassen steigen in
die u-bahn und infiziert haben aber das
gefühl sie werden es nicht
heckings frage eine frage an beide auch
ersparen sie haben gesagt der ballermann
darf nicht gespielt werden ein großer
unterschied zwischen beiden ist ja dass
ich hier vor allem in engen
geschlossenen räumen gefeiert wurde war
man welches die bilder richtig gesehen
habe draußen deswegen würde mich mal
interessieren ob es inzwischen deutlich
neue erkenntnisse zur ansteckung
situationen gibt vielleicht auch von
angela aus denen rückverfolgung des der
gesundheitsämter inwieweit im freien ist
eigentlich schon zu ansteckungen
gekommen es war zumindest die waren
damals nach dem größten demonstration
nur diesen ersten teil und partys haben
jetzt nicht zu sichtbaren ticks geführt
meine frage gibt es nach nachgewiesene
größere ansteckung im freien und sich
kreuzberg haben wir tatsächlich in 200
auch die wissenschaft und wir mit ihr
beim infektionsgeschehen die
infektionsrisiken bezüglich der eurozone
auch die weko hat ja gerade ihre
einschätzung zu erholen
überarbeitet viel gelernt wir im übrigen
auch gelernt dass das thema
schmierinfektionen also was anfassen
desinfizieren relativ weniger ein thema
ist und dafür eben das thema aero sohle
und dass die atmen wir schon aus dafür
muss ich gar nicht wussten einfach nur
sitzen und atmen machen einen
unterschied insbesondere in
geschlossenen räumen
deswegen also wenn ich manche
situationen auch in der stadt der
fahrradfahrer mit der maske macht
natürlich jetzt für das infektionsrisiko
keinen unterschied bei dem bei dem wind
und der umwelt schadet auch nicht aber
bis jetzt macht jetzt an der stelle
keinen unterschied mache vor allem ein
unterschied im geschlossenen raum
das problem beim feiern ist ja ein
anderes wenn sie wenn sie haben
wenn ich die bilder vom ostseestrand
sehe und ich weiß da wird die
meeresbrise und alle passen bisschen
aufeinander auf da werde ich noch nicht
gleich nervös wenn ich aber sehe und wir
kennen uns doch alle wie das ist wenn
man feiert wenn dieselbe flasche um
gereicht wird aus der getrunken wird
wenn man sich umarmt und viele
jedenfalls beim feiern und unter
alkoholgenuss im zweifel auch nähe
suchen dann potenziert ist natürlich das
risiko und deswegen ist das gar nicht
mehr sehen sozusagen nur das draußensein
sondern die ganze situation die feiern
einfach mit sich bringt und ich bin
jetzt wirklich kein spielverderber oder
spaßverderber oder fire verächter aber
es ist halt gar nicht die zeit dafür
und wenn man das verständnis miteinander
haben dann können wir schon einen
unterschied machen ich höre jetzt schon
wie die ersten irgendwie devisen
alternativ partys zu hause organisieren
weil die wiesen ausfallen also das war
jetzt nicht der sinn dahinter das weil
die riesen ausfallen jetzt alle in ihren
privatwohnungen devisen ersatz feier
verlegen an der stelle
und deswegen ist es jetzt mehr die
situation des feierns und ausgelassen
sein die dann eben risiko wieder erhöht
aber sie haben recht im geschlossenen
raum im zweifel noch stärker natürlich
erhöht als ihm nicht geschlossene
ja ich also diese abstand und diese zeit
regel die gelten ja unabhängig von innen
und außen und wir sagen ja also wenn man
das eben nicht einhalten kann
dann kommt zusätzlich noch die maske
dazu dass er dieses grundtenor
selbstverständlich geschieht das draußen
nicht so leicht wie drinnen aber
prinzipiell können sie natürlich auch
draußen durch tröpfcheninfektion ohne
maske jemand anderen infizieren und das
ist genau der aspekt der nähe und der
zeitlichen zusammenkunft und insofern
haben wir gelernt dass euro solle eine
größere rolle spielen als wir das vor
einigen wochen noch wussten und dass es
besondere umgebung gibt in geschlossenen
räumen chor ausbrüche beim singen haben
wir gelernt sie gespielt eine große es
gibt bestimmte settings für das sagen wo
die ansteckungsgefahr eben noch größer
ist aber deshalb ist ja in anderen
settings nicht weg also dieser abstand
150 15 minuten diese regeln die wir
haben sind innen und außen sinnvoll und
was nicht geht trägt man eben nochmals
zusätzlich ich nehme an dieser stelle
nochmal eine frage aus dem digital
natürlich schließt sich ganz gut an und
regeln eine etwas andere richtung der
kollege wegen der von dpa afx ragt das
etwa 1 5 einen fünftel der bevölkerung
das risiko einer zweiten welle für
unwahrscheinlich eingeschätzt hätten sie
es vor diesen hintergrund für notwendig
zu den beschränkungen zurückzukehren und
das risiko durch die in
anführungszeichen unbelehrbaren zum
linien die vor gericht ersparen
also grundsätzlich einmal kann ja keiner
von uns ausschließen dass es eine zweite
welle gibt insbesondere wenn sich die
jahreszeit auch noch mal verändert ich
lerne gerade viel auch nochmal
möglicherweise die immunologische
situation des des körpers in der
biologie verändert aber eben auch unser
verhalten sich verändert vor allem auch
in der frage
in welchen räumen geschlossen nicht
geschlossen halten wir uns auf das kann
niemand ausschließen und wir wollen uns
darauf vorbereiten sie kommt aber auch
nicht automatisch sondern schlicht an
uns selbst und deswegen stimme ich
grundsätzlich an wegen dazu umso mehr
mitmachen sich an bestimmte regeln
halten im alltag desto geringer ist eben
dieses risiko aber gleichzeitig geht es
bei jeder beschränkende maßnahmen auch
im verhältnismäßigkeit und angemessen
erhalt und die jetzt sozusagen präventiv
an dieser stelle und für das ganze
bundesgebiet sehe ich das nicht was wir
ja auch sehen ist das wenn wir um so
schneller wir auch lokale regionale
ausbrüche möglicherweise auch wie in
gütersloh geschehen wieder durch
beschränkungen in dem jeweiligen
landkreis oder nachdem
oberverwaltungsgerichts urteil
zielgenauer auf die betroffenen kommunen
dann gemacht werden
ein übergreifen in andere regionen oder
bevölkerungsteile auch eben verhindert
werden kann und das ist jetzt das
konzept der wahl genießen sind also
infiziert waren
die dann nach einiger zeit wieder zurück
gehen also schwächer werden
wie bewerten sie das bzw das wäre ja
auch ein problem wenn man irgendwann am
anfang der familie 60 bis 70 prozent der
bevölkerung müssten diese antikörper
haben wenn die nach zwei monaten wieder
verschwinden wird es ja sicherlich
schwierig auch was den herbst an geht
zum beispiel die nächsten jahr ja es ist
generell so es gibt ja in der
bevölkerung auch noch andere coroner wie
in die sogenannten erkältungsviren die
wir seit hunderten tausenden von jahren
kennen und generell ist es so dass gegen
korona wir nicht sehr sehr gute hohe
antikörpertiter produziert werden nach
den infektionen das weiß man also auch
schon von diesen coronaviren es ist
tatsächlich so dass mit den methoden mit
denen wir arbeiten diesen antikörper
tests manche antikörper dann zu gering
also in der menge
mit quasi vorkommen dass wir sie noch
nachweisen können wir wissen aber
momentan noch nicht ob das in
irgendeiner weise eine assoziation zur
immunität hat also zum also dem schutz
quasi durch seine in deutsche infektion
wir können das einfach nicht beantworten
weil wir das virus erst einen guten 7
monaten kennen und wir wissen allerdings
dass ist eine anderen arm der
immunantwort gibt die sogenannten
t-zellen da wissen wir dass es eine
reihe von den patienten gibt oder die
mehrheit der patienten die eine
infektion durch gewartet dass die
reaktivität sein haben wir denken dass
das auch die immunität vermittelt und es
gibt auch neue befunde die dafür
sprechen dass die antikörper auch wenn
man sie mit den herkömmlichen tests gar
nicht nachweisen kann dass trotzdem dort
noch zellen sind und antikörper die noch
eine neutralisierende wirkung haben das
sind neueste ergebnisse das ist alles
stark im fluss und wir dürfen glaube ich
stand heute können wir nicht sagen dass
die menschen bei denen ihr keine
antikörper nachweisen dass die nicht
auch immun werden wir wissen dass noch
nicht genau werden dass im laufe der
nächsten monate aber denke ich alles die
wissenschaftler herausfinden wie bringen
wenn ich das noch hinzufügen darf gibt
es ja interessante studien die wir uns
natürlich an meinen näher anschauen wie
es miteinander
ob das durchgemacht haben einer
infektion mit einem der anderen kroner
während in den t zellen zu einer solchen
antwort geführt hat dass es gleich keine
immunität aber zu milderen verlauf führt
bei diesem corona virus da gibt es erste
erkenntnis dass wir ja auch spannend das
ist jetzt noch weiter zu zu beleuchten
wie finanzierende auch teilstudien zu
aber es wird natürlich zur frage der
risikoeinschätzung dann auch noch mal
ein unterschied macht
ich habe eine frage zur entwicklung der
impfstoffe in thüringen beginnen ja nun
die fest seine freiwilligen würde gerne
von ihnen beiden
wir sind wie optimistisch sind dass das
zu einem erfolg führen kann also erst
wenn man frau bestimmt nicht
optimistisch dass es deutlich mehr
freiwillige deutlich wichtig über
deutlich mehr freiwillige gegeben hat
die sich impfen lassen wollten als
tatsächlich probanden überhaupt
eingeschlossen werden in die studie was
er zeigt dass es durchaus eine hohe
bereitschaft zur impfung auch in der
bevölkerung
da ist zum zweiten ist es erstmal
überhaupt viel versprechend dass wir so
hinreichend viele kandidaten
impfstoffkandidaten in deutschland aber
auch international haben die schon phase
2 3 erreicht haben in vergleichsweise
kurzer zeit was auch mit vor forschung
zu tun hat dies aus anderen
zusammenhängen eben gibt und auch mit
einem zusammenwirken im engagement und
den polen von kräften und ressourcen wie
wir das wahrscheinlich so noch nie zuvor
auch in der menschheitsgeschichte hatten
wenn es um das entwickeln eines
impfstoffes geht
gleichzeitig sind impfstoffe das ist
etwas was am gesunden menschen vererbt
wird wurde natürlich die
risikoabschätzung noch mal was anderes
ist als wenn es um 1 1 ein
krebsmedikament oder was anderes ginge
es wird auch viel viel häufiger verimpft
müssen wir davon ausgehen dass ein
impfstoff möglicherweise 123 milliarden
mal verimpft würde
und natürlich die frage welche wirkungen
und nebenwirkungen es gibt dann noch
einmal auch eine sehr besondere rolle
spielt und deswegen glaube ich stand
heute niemand verlässlich wenn sie
fragen
das ist vielversprechend wir sind
zuversichtlich mit dem was wir sehen und
im stand phase 2 3 bei so vielen
kandidaten aber eine garantie gibt es
mit dem staat auch dieser studien geben
noch nichts das es nicht noch
erkenntnisse geben kann das finde ich
immer wichtig dazu zu sagen
die dann auch erstmal bedeuten dass es
doch länger dauert stand heute
ist anlass für optimismus da ja ich kann
das nur ein also es gibt drei
verschiedene art von impfstoffen es gibt
sehr viele impfstoffkandidaten drei
verschiedene arten ist innovative ist
halt dass mit dieser messenger rna also
dass man ein rna impfstoff gibt das ist
das was für weg tut und andere firmen
dann gibt es lebend impfstoffe die quasi
bestimmte antigene dieses virus dem
immunsystem präsentieren und eine gute
antikörper antworten dann gibt es tot im
stoffe also ich bin sehr optimistisch
dass es im stoffe geben wird wie gut die
wirken wie lange die schützen werden
wird man dann natürlich sehen im laufe
der zeit es ist vorher nicht so leicht
vorherzusagen und ein wichtiger punkt
ist genau der auch minister sparen
ansprach wir müssen natürlich die
sicherheitsprofil der ihm stoffe immer
im blick haben und die zähne zeigen sich
eben auch erst wenn man intensivere
studien getätigt hat um dann zu sehen ob
es nebenwirkungen gibt die man
akzeptiert oder nicht
das gesamtportfolio wird man dann testen
aber was wirklich großartig hier ist ist
die art und weise wie viele menschen
weltweit und firmen und wissenschaftler
sich zusammengeschlossen haben um das zu
ermöglichen
das stimmt ein sehr optimistischer sind
ja mittlerweile sechseinhalb milliarden
steuergelder ausgeschüttet worden
wir haben jetzt hinweise darauf dass
zumindest in einigen kliniken diese
auswahl welche werden freigehalten
werden nicht nach medizinischen
kriterien erfolg seiner finanziellen
tieren also sprich das vor allem als
sprache fachbereichen gesperrt werden
wer in innovativen bereichen weiter die
betten ersetzt werden
dazu die frage sehen sie die gefahr dass
es möglicherweise zu so einer schieflage
kommt man ja gar nicht beabsichtigt und
müsste diesem hintergrund nicht auch für
mehr transparenz und kontrolle gesorgt
werden unseres wissens nach ist es ja im
moment so dass auch hier hausen ich weiß
welche wetten eigentlich komplett frei
gehalten werden und auch nicht
kontrolliert werden
diese frei gemeldeten tatsächlich auch
zuerst einmal gibt es das risiko dass
wir beschreiben ohne zweifel
übrigens auch in anderen bereichen in
der psychiatrie mussten wir feststellen
dass ist aufgrund der pauschale fürs
nicht belegte bett in der höhe ist
anreize geben kann die betten nicht zu
belegen und das ist natürlich nicht das
was intendiert war sondern war sehr
intendiert war war entschädigung zu
geben für die vorbereitung wenn wir uns
erinnern dann mitte märz als die
entscheidung getroffen wurde
auf eben auch die mögliche welle
deswegen haben wir eine verordnung
vorgelegt die am dritten siebten vom
bundesrat auch dem zugestimmt wurde das
seit dem ersten siebten rückwirkend
diese 560 euro pro watt pro tag
sozusagen aufgefächert wurde für
universitätsmedizin und maximalversorger
höher
für viele andere aber auch niedriger um
genau solche anreize zumindest schon mal
deutlich zu reduzieren
es könnte natürlich auch ein
merkwürdiges medizinisches verständnis
dazu das so zu handhaben und sehr
fragwürdig ist nicht nur merkwürdig ist
sehr fragwürdiges und hinterfragt bares
und zu hinterfragen das eine kontrolle
der zahlung gibt es in diesem fall aber
eben sozusagen nachgelagert also die
meldungen welche krankenhäuser in
welchem umfang die gelder bekommen haben
die werden wir das läuft der bis 30
september danach gelagert bekommen und
dann natürlich auch werden sie jetzt
kontrolle geben können was natürlich
nicht geht das wird ja auch in den
krankenkassen daten zu sehen sein ist
das für dasselbe bett
behandlung abrechnen und das ist dann
schon mehr als nur fragwürdig dass
betrug an der stelle und dann noch freie
freiheiten pauschale entsprechend und
das ist das was ich vorhin sagte auch
mit wir können die kapazitäten besser
steuern also eine pauschale maßnahme
würde man stand heute für eine mögliche
neue situation nicht noch mal treffen
aber in der damaligen situation ist es
noch nie gegeben in deutschland dass wir
sozusagen irgendwie betten frei ziehen
mussten wollten intensivbetten in
größerem umfang nicht wissend auch in
welchem umfang wir sie brauchen würden
stand heute wissen wir haben auch
digitale tools dafür mit dem die divi
register intensivbetten und anderes mehr
könnten wir viel besser regional die
bettenkapazitäten steuern und wissen wie
viel schneller sie entsprechend frei
werden aber ja auch ich höre solche
meldungen und ich wenn sie daran
arbeiten was da auf zu arbeiten kann ich
das nur begrüßen
eine letzte frage ist im digitalen von
der kollegin entschuldigung wieder
wollten sie dazu auch noch was sagen
unterbrechen sozusagen genau aus dem
digitalen die kollegin anna krey von der
deutschen welle türkei fragt an sie herr
sparen wie bewerten sie die
entwicklungen in der türkei was würden
was würden sie bürgern in deutschland
empfehlen gegen die türkei reisen
möchten im moment stand heute geht die
reisewarnung ja noch ich sage auch
deswegen weil wir uns ja auch innerhalb
der europäischen union vereinbart haben
regelmäßig die liste und das machen wir
ja korrelieren miteinander die liste aus
von drittstaaten aus denen einreise
wieder möglich ist nach europa
korrigiert natürlich auch mit der liste
derjenigen länder für die wir als
bundesregierung eine reisewarnung
aussprechen das macht der in jeder
hinsicht sinn
und diese liste wird regelmäßig
überarbeitet und insofern wird jetzt
natürlich auch die situation in der
türkei noch mal betrachtet werden und
dann geht es darum welches
infektionsgeschehen ist dort gibt und
gleichzeitig eben auch um die konzepte
wissen sie
gibt er da zwei drei themen die uns
gemeinsam beschäftigen müssen
das eine ist die frage urlaub im hotel
im ressort die verschiedenen konzepte
die es da gibt gibt es wahrscheinlich
auch eine hohe standards der konzepte
was abstand angeht was wir gene angeht
und das andere sind natürlich auch die
fragen der privaten reisen die ich auch
gut verstehen und bin sich gegenseitig
sehen innerhalb der familie und der
verwandtschaft aber auch dort ist es
genauso wichtig wie beim hotel urlaub
das abstand so weit es geht eingehalten
wird und bestimmte regeln beachtet
werden weil natürlich auch dort
infektionsrisiken bestehen und wenn die
türkei ist schaffte täglich aktualisiert
auch regional differenzierte zahlen zu
haben verlässlich dann könnten wir
natürlich so wie wir es ja auch bei
anderen ländern oder auch bei uns in
deutschland machen auch nochmal regional
differenziert schauen und ich weiß dass
es großes bemühen auf türkischer seite
gibt auch das jetzt noch zwei fragen von
herrn jugend sicherlich okay dann
verbrannt und dann machen wir eine
zweite fragerunde und gucken wie weit
wir kommen mit blick auf die folgen der
regierungspressekonferenz ich habe sie
auch mit ihren nachfragen auf der liste
wir gucken wie weit wir kommen aber erst
mal flog es ist ja nur tanja brandes in
der berliner zeitung hallo ich habe eine
frage an herrn brüner und zwar geht noch
mal ein bisschen eine ganz andere
richtung und zwar ich habe hier eine
zusammenfassung die wir auch haben
gelesen dass sie sagen oder das
herausgekommen ist das man pauschal
diese pauschale aussage dass vor allem
frauen von den folgen besonders
betroffen sind dass man das so nicht
treffen kann
andererseits haben sie auch gerade
und das kommt auch in diesem gesehen
habe in den zahlen immer wieder die
betonung dass es vor allem die
alleinerziehenden frauen besonders
getroffen hat und gleichzeitig die
geringer beschäftigten bestehe besonders
geringe zwei beschäftigten berufen tätig
sind ist es deutlich dass nicht doch
darauf hin dass gerade die frauen trifft
oder kommt vielleicht können sie genauer
sagen was sie damit meinen jetzt sei
aber was zu sagen die zahlen meines
pauschal nichts zu sagen oder für welche
bereiche ist tatsächlich zutreffen
könnte ich denke das was ich klar
herausschält ist dass es die
alleinerziehende frauen sind das ist ja
nicht die mehrzahl der frauen und nur
generell müssen wir das nochmal im
einzelnen cent gucken auch nochmal
differenzieren
aber was häufig auch von einigen in der
sozialwissenschaft behauptet wird das
ist nur die die frau als
überproportional trifft das können wir
im augenblick aus den daten noch nicht
heraus schließen
gleichwohl und deswegen haben wir im
übrigen diese studie auch mit beauftragt
hat das nach allem was wir ja auch
selbst denke ich empfinden sozusagen in
dem was gesehen ein phänomen und
deswegen ist es gut dass auch
wissenschaftlich zu unterlegen hat das
eine soziale komponente
diese pandemie das fängt an bei der
frage ich meine homeschooling ist jetzt
auch nicht in jeder situation
gleichermaßen möglich zum beispiel die
frage welt was heißt das für welche
bildungssituation die frage was heißt
das für welche beschäftigungssituation
natürlich ganz besonders was heißt das
für berufstätige eltern und dann noch
auch gerade für alleinerziehende
was heißt das für bestimmte
arbeitssituationen ob sie im schlachthof
arbeiten oder home office machen weil
sie ministerium arbeiten das macht alles
einen unterschied und hat auch soziale
komponenten und ich finde es sehr
wichtig dass wir diese soziale frage
dieser pandemie auch adressieren und
besprechen
und deswegen haben wir eben und die
umfrage und die studie ist ja noch so zu
sein zwischenergebnis im weiteren gang
auch diese studie beauftragt
wieder über welchen fehler in den
letzten vier monaten ärgern sie sich als
lka-präsident am meisten also fehler des
lka oder ihre arbeit unter sparen zu der
app 15 5 millionen 15 5 millionen sind
schön aber die experten sprechen davon
dass zwei drittel der bevölkerung die
app runter runter geladen und nutzen
müssen damit es zu einer optimalen
rückverfolgung kommen kann wie wollen
sie das schaffen dass zwei drittel der
bevölkerung die app nutzen
herr jungen die von ihnen zitierten
experten haben sehr deutlich gemacht
leider werden immer nur unvollständig
zitiert dass die zwei drittel erreicht
werden müssen wenn man sonst überhaupt
keine anderen maßnahmen ergreifen würde
es genau das gleiche wie beim impfen
dass man etwa zwei drittel immunität
braucht in der größenordnung um
unterschied zu machen da wir aber eher
eine ganze reihe weiterer maßnahmen
ergreifen und wir haben heute schon
einige besprochen vom abstand halten und
alltags maske angefangen kontakt
nachverfolgung viele andere maßnahmen
braucht es nicht zwei drei ein
unterschied zu machen und da ich ja weiß
dass sie immer wichtige
aufklärungsarbeit auch in den sozialen
medien machen wäre ich sehr dankbar wenn
dieser umstand zu den zwei dritteln dass
die immer nicht einsortiert sozusagen
werden in diesem gesamtkontext nur dann
wenn keine anderen maßnahmen ergriffen
werden
vielleicht auch noch mal vermitteln
könnten weil ich krieg die frage häufig
gestellt auch in verschiedenen kontexten
und das bin ich bei ihnen muss man
vernünftig aufklären
gleichwohl freuen wir uns natürlich über
jeden über die 15,5 millionen hinaus der
noch zusätzlich mit macht bei diesem
team spiel und die app herunterlädt aber
schon 15,5 millionen die sie nutzen
machen einen unterschied
gute frage man vor hinterfragt sich ja
eigentlich ständig und überarbeitet
seinen gedanken gebilde jeden tag
wir haben im robert koch institut unter
anderem ja täglich zeitweise jetzt sind
es nur noch drei mal in der woche
krisensitzung in diesen krisen sitzung
besprechen wir alle dinge alle vorgänge
die wir
vorher durchgesprochen haben und
bewerten sie neu und und wir verbessern
uns jeden tag und das werden wir auch
die nächsten monate noch machen solange
es diese krise geben wird in unserem
land und dann werden wir schauen wie gut
wir durch diese krise kommen ich hatte
nach einem fehler gefragt zu werden doch
ein fehler gemacht haben über den sie
sich am meisten ärgern
ja aber ich kann ihnen keinen nennen
über den meisten berger
aber vielleicht darf ich jetzt einfach
wieder der nächste kollege die fragen
stellen geschlagen wurde beantwortet
sowie das ist eine bewertung sache
haring auch die frage andere zu einem
etwas anderen punkt und zwar gibt es
chinesische warnung dass in kaarst haben
jetzt eine neue krankheit ausgebrochen
ist die aufschläge fällig sein sollte
mich würde interessieren ob sie dazu
irgendwelche daten haben oder
einschätzungen wie gefährlich dieser
ausbruch es in irgendeiner form
vergleichbar mit dem chor währung also
wir haben keine daten darüber
wir haben keine erkenntnisse stand heute
liegen wir keine erkenntnisse vor ob es
sich doch um eine neue lunge
infektionskrankheit handelt sondern wir
gehen davon aus dass es eben kubik 19
ist es gibt in china wurde vor kurzem
ein neues virus ein instruments hat
virus identifiziert das bei schweinen
ursprung den ursprung von schwein hat
ein virus das das potenzial hat ein
gewisses pandemische potenzial von den
gehen also von den erbgut analysen die
wir kennen und von den daten die dann im
labor erhoben wurden dieses virus
bislang nach den informationen die uns
vorliegen ist dass josef bislang nicht
breitet sich das nicht aus das ist der
einzige kenntnisstand den ich zurzeit
habe in dem zusammenhang ist vielleicht
auch wichtig zu wissen dass wir weltweit
ja influenza betrachten müssen dass wir
influenza jedes jahr auch eben schon
gegen influenza und wir sehen weltweit
dass es manche regionen gibt die die
sogenannte syriens die überwachung auf
influenza in den letzten monaten
vernachlässigt haben uns einfach aus
kostengründen weil sich im hauptsächlich
noch im cockpit 19 kümmern mussten
und es ist sehr wichtig dass diese
untersuchungen weiter durchgeführt
werden denn nach wie vor auch wenn wir
natürlich co fit und sehr stark darauf
konzentrieren gibt es natürlich
influenzaviren die wir beachten müssen
und ihren auch immer ausgewählt werden
müssen um die entsprechenden impfstoff
herzustellen die wir jedes jahr auf die
süd oder noch kalt kugel stellen wir
verschiedene impfstoffe
also es wichtig dass wir auch die
anderen viren im blick halten und
natürlich ist auch wichtig wenn
der neue lungenkrankheiten entstehen
oder auftreten dass man die im blick hat
das ist sehr sehr wichtig das dürfe
nicht verlassen bringen wird die
bundesrepublik deutschland diesmal über
soviel grippe impfstoff verfügen mit
über 25 millionen dosen wie noch zu
keiner grippesaison
umso wichtiger wäre ist dass wir
möglichst viele bürgerinnen und bürger
vom sinn einer grippeimpfung grad in
diesen zeiten überzogen mit blick auf
die zeit dass wir noch zweiter haben für
den wechsel würde ich noch eine letzte
frage nehmen mit bitte um kurze fragen
kurze antwort auf eine frage die ich
direkt etwas mit unserem alter zu tun
pflegepersonal stärkung des gesetzes
anderthalb jahre jetzt auf dem markt
welche konkreten verbesserung hat dieses
gesetz das pflegepersonal stärkung
gesetz dass er tatsächlich schon vor
dieser pandemie die uns ja noch mal
allen auch die wichtigkeit der
pflegeberufe vor augen geführt hat hat
sehr starke auswirkung vor allem in der
krankenpflege es ist ja eine veränderung
in der finanzierung der krankenpfleger
das leben ist auch wichtig ist für die
debatte zum pflege zur pflege prämie
denn tatsächlich würde eine gezielte
pflege prämie der krankenhäuser
refinanziert werden von den
krankenkassen
wenn sich die arbeitgeber als
krankenhäuser dazu entscheiden sie
auszuzahlen 40 bestandteil des pflege
budgets und die pflege budgets also das
was ein krankenhaus im jahr für pflege
ausgibt wird refinanziert von den
krankenkassen und das ist eine andere
situation als in der altenpflege
deswegen haben wir eben die gesetzliche
regelung in der altenpflege getroffen
die sie kennen und gleichzeitig setzt
sich in der krankenpflege darauf dass
krankenhäuser als arbeitgeber
insbesondere für diejenigen die in der
intensivmedizin sehr stark gefordert
waren 19 patienten eben auch
entsprechende prämien
dann vorsehen das hat das pflegepersonal
stärkung gesetz zum beispiel möglich
gemacht diese finanzierung die
refinanzierung von allen
tarifsteigerungen das einführen von
personal untergrenzen noch mal verstärkt
für viele bereiche und für das
krankenhaus insgesamt also das sind
verhältnis setzen gibt von patientenzahl
zur zahl der pflegekräfte und 13.000
zusätzliche stellen in der stationären
altenhilfe
das war ein digitales
investitionsprogramm ich könnte jetzt
tatsächlich aber ich darf nicht fünf bis
zehn minuten darüber berichten was in
diesem pflegepersonal stärkung gesetz an
wichtigen größeren und kleinen baustein
zur verbesserung in der pflege schon
enthalten war
aber wir arbeiten hier an der
konzertierten pflege daran auch aktionen
pflege in der konzertierten aktion
pflege da waren von der
berufsperspektive über die dinge des
alltags den beruf noch weiter
attraktiver zu machen
mit der bitte um verständnis dass wir
nicht mehr alle fragen beantworten
konnten
und hier aufnehmen konnten vielen dank
für ihre fragen vielen dank an uns
vergessen dass sie sich den fragen
gestellt haben und ich würde sie bitten
um einen schnellen wechsel weil die
kollegen unten schon warten für die
folgende tk vielen dank
[Musik]